I want ketchup that's my intro I'm Liz
and I love ketchup and I'm gonna blow
this test out of the water
I'm Nate and I also love ketchup and I'm
gonna blow this test more out of the
water
I'm Shelby I'm Nick and we're taste
testing different types of ketchup and I
would catch a pro been eatin since about
1993 so I've had every kind of ketchup
I've had all kinds of fancy ketchup
vinegar ketchup spicy ketchup sweet
ketchup so bring it at me many of my
friends have caught me just squeezing
the ketchup onto my finger and eating it
or if I have extra ketchup packets that
like in and out or something I'll just
use the ketchup packet into my mouth I'm
actually a ketchup master and I've been
having ketchup since 1991 okay yeah when
were you born 1981 good ketchup just
makes you go wow it just takes any food
elevates it to the next level
bad ketchup you're just it's just like
you're putting a slop on the food and it
just makes your food not Wow Wow
yeah let's do it let's bring it I'm
ready for the ketchup 1 2 3
Oh the holy grail of french fries it's
like the smell you get when you're like
in a ball pit it's so good
I actually kind of really don't ask
questions I just was this is McDonald's
ketchup you know one point they called
this fancy ketchup that's what they put
on there
I don't like it quite as much no I don't
like I don't like the Vinnie green is I
think I've always thought this like a
Mad King with sauce in my head when I'm
eating with Tom's fries as a kid like I
feel like this ketchup takes away the
McDonald's fry flavor hmm so I usually
open it and I do like one fry and I like
I do it like yeah I'll do that
top oh you're not fat well I wouldn't
say that I like dislike it like if I was
like stranded on the island and those
all I had to eat I would eat it yeah
he's just doing nice yeah yeah I'm just
yeah good waft it you know yeah for me
I'm very neutral on it I'm fine with it
obviously like I would go with a
different sauce from McDonald's but if
it's like all they have okay this is
like your childhood in a packet it's a
little fancier the container is
different no more plastic pack it's
already I can tell it's darker so it's a
much richer red hmm looks nice color
yeah he's got a good colour deep nice
color
no stank it smells sweeter it is
definitely sweeter now that you
mentioned the vinegar it's really hard
not to think about the bitter
yeah well you learn something new every
day let's watch it okay I have a feeling
this one's gonna be less sweet all right
let's try this
mason jar ketchup you're George Sr yeah
okay I can't eat it with the fries it
gets mixed in and this one to me is a
little bit bland honestly yeah there's
no yeah which is surprising for how much
it it smelled like that yeah I know I
thought it was gonna be like even smoky
sort of but yeah Alison's not really
doing anything for me to be honest
crabs are so good it's interesting I
like it this is Heinz mrs. Heinz
maybe I'll get like one more fries just
you know just to be safe I'll show ya
this is it's like you said it's like
this makes your food not Wow
yeah please don't try and fool me with
your jar next okay Oh
oh my gosh five-star treatment oh why
thank you
Wow are we having spaghetti seeing some
little snow flecks in there
hmm take it this is a fancy one
it's got flecks in it I've never seen
ketchup like this before yeah it smells
oh I smell truffle
I think truffle oil oh all if there's
anything in this world that I love its
ketchup and it's truffles oh my god yeah
there's like some dark whoa that was
really yeah I guess we just got a dip
[Music]
yes truffle ketchup the Sun it's so good
this is the good stuff right here Oh
ma'am you see now this is taking this
fry from like a good fry - oh wow for a
while fry oh we should trademark that
Wow fry I don't know what you're waiting
for
I serve it before you try it put part of
it it taste is a visual appeal of it
yeah I literally just drooled like it's
so good
Wow I don't like truffle that much I
think it's super overrated people just
like it because it's fancy so I am very
hesitant I don't think I'm gonna like
this one quite as much violet ooh wow it
was right I don't like this one quite as
much
this is like an adequate amount of
country for me most most people they do
the little you know little tiny puddle
no I need like a pool oh I kinda like
this one the most
tub them all like if it wasn't presented
so elegantly I still would have been
able to tell that it's the fanciest one
keep going I really liked the third
ketchup the best because a I love
truffle can't go wrong with truffles you
see it actually did taste like ketchup
head still had a nice vinegary flavor
and see very very good consistency and D
I just wanted to lick it off the plate
that's an indescribable quality I liked
the
Hinds number two the best and the third
one the police husband I want to see it
after I like the most expensive one the
best
how much can for $24 that little jar
right there I don't think I like it
anymore $24 is $4 that's a lot of a lot
of clams for ketchup
I think ketchup is the number one
condiment
if you can argue with me the comments
think I'm wrong but there's really no
condiment better than ketchup it's good
on everything a life without ketchup is
a life not truly lived facts
[Music]